[Musique]
lorsque vous allez chez votre médecin
vous vous attendez à ce que l'uci a
suivi des études pour devenir médecin
une formation qu'il a préparée à son
métier de même lorsqu'on recrute un
ingénieur allemand à celui ci a été
formé une longue formation universitaire
pour les préparations métier et enfin
n'imagine pas non plus un avocat qui
viendraient qui n'auraient pas fait
d'études ont révélé louis launay et
c'est tout à fait normal et ces trois
personnes là sont passés par
l'enseignement supérieur pourtant il ya
un paradoxe dans ce système là c'est que
les gens qui forment ses avocats ses
ingénieurs ses médecins ont eux mêmes
n'ont même pas été formé jeudi pas là
que ceux qui enseignent aux ingénieurs
ne sont pas scientifiques a dû tout vécu
dans leur métier d'enseignant lorsqu'il
faut cours ils n'ont pas reçu de
formation digne de ce nom la plupart des
enseignants qui intervient dans
l'enseignement supérieur n'ont pas reçu
une formation digne de ce nom du pied
récemment il y à une formation
obligatoire qui est dispensé cette
formation variant entre une trentaine
d'heures et 120 heures
on peut se dire c'est déjà bien mais il
faut comparer ce chiffre là à la
formation que reçoivent les enseignants
du secondaire ce qui enseigne au collège
et en lycée j ils ont deux ans
d'information deux ans dont à peu près
1500 heures aux temps de la pédagogie
alors est-ce que c'est grave
finalement est-ce que c'est grave parce
qu'on a besoin de pédagogie pour
enseigner dans l'enseignement supérieur
en 2003 de psychologue cognitif de renom
ont fait l'analyse suivante ils ont
conclu que le système actuel était en
totale contradiction avec la manière
dont la prenait avec toutes les
recherches la condition autrement dit la
manière on tourne enseigne n'est pas
compatible avec la manière dont notre
cerveau à prendre avec des collègues de
l'université toulouse on s'est
intéressés ne se pouvait à notre échelle
changer les choses on a regardé une
méthode à une méthode pédagogique qui
s'appelle le pire instruction qui est
utilisé dans de nombreuses universités
étrangères
on a voulu l'appliquer cette méthode
étaient adaptés à l'enseignement aux
amphis dans cette situation là mais elle
transformée l'amphi où le prophète
essentiellement en train de parler
pendant que les ide en écoute
as tu une situation où les étudiants
sont mises réflexion et sont mis en
discussion entre ' si les étudiants
discutent aurait discute pas de leur
week-end mais en fait ils discutent du
cours du cours que l'on enseigne du
contenu il essaye de se l'accaparer de
le comprendre et l'enseignant et la
tourner et leur apporte des retours du
feedback
au final on est passé à une situation où
le message principal c'est tétouan
écoute suivi dans suite de tétouan y
écoute encore comme ça pendant des
heures et des heures assure une
situation où willy a toujours ce message
là on dit tais toi et écoute
mais ensuite on introduit des moments
des moments de réflexion des moments une
discussion et le coup magistral est
ensuite une alternance de ces moments là
démission la part de l'enseignant qui
transmet des connaissances à la
réception des étudiants qui vont céder
comprend les manipuler les mettant en
situation
alors est ce que ça marche mieux on a
fait dans le cas d'un des cours de
physique en première année universitaire
des mesures précises une étude
expérimentale rigoureuse il ya une tête
est très claire les étudiants apprenez
mieux avec cette nouvelle méthode et ses
résultats qu'on a obtenus localement 100
parfait accord avec toutes les études
internationales en 2014 une étude qui
analyse et puis de 255 autres études
elle en a fait la synthèse est dense et
250 autres études il y avait la
comparaison entre un cours où
l'enseignant majoritairement du d'en
parler et majoritairement dit-on les
étudiants écoutent et à d'autres où la
vie s'est mise en situation régulière
tout au long du cours de discussion les
étudiants est émis soit individuellement
réflexion soit collectivement par les
différents travaux et le résultat est
sans appel ce dans lequel les mes études
ont été mis régulièrement aux travaux
apprenez bienvenue en particulier sur
les chèques
lorsque les enseignants étaient
uniquement mode magistral on observait
un tiers des chèques
autant dire un étudiant sur trois ne
réussissait pas alors que lorsqu'il
avait 6 mise en pratique cet échec
diminué à 20%
et lorsqu'il avait beaucoup de mise en
pratique de mise en situation
alors on dit tombé à 10 % d'échec
au final en changeant de méthode
pédagogique on arrive à diviser par
trois les chèques des étudiants alors
pourquoi c'est si compliqué finalement
toutes ces études là toutes ces méthodes
pédagogiques elles sont publiées elles
sont accessibles mais en fait elle
questionne l faut complètement changé la
manière dont on voit les choses elle
redéfinit ce que c'est que faire quoi
est ce que c'est qu'être un bon prof un
bon prof on a souvent l'image suivante
le bon prof c'est le bon orateur celui
qui explique bien celui qui capte
l'attention des élèves et enfin ce que
nous dit la recherche et que c'est pas
la bonne image
la bonne image c'est plutôt qu'un bon
prof c'est celle du coach sportif
il définit des objectifs il évalue les
étudiants ils évaluent leurs
performances il les entraîne hillairet
entraîne encore et les évalue
régulièrement jusqu'à obtenir la
performance désiré
ça change tout parce que même à
l'orateur qui parlent bien au final ils
l'engagent plus intellectuellement les
étudiants alors on a tous en mémoire un
bon prof qui était un bon orateur zhihua
où il est super ce incroyable discours
mais en fait ce qu'il faut bien penser
c'est même si c'est important
les anciennes n'est pas ce que l'on dit
est ce que l'on fait en tant
qu'enseignant l'abandonnent n'est pas de
se concentrer sur son discours
l'important est de se focaliser sur ce
que font les étudiants toute l'attention
d'un bon prendre la tête focaliser sur
les étudiants sur chacun des étudiants
pour savoir ce qu'ils font à quoi ils
pensent où ils en sont pour les guider
cette image là du bon orateur du prof
comme l'orateur venant dispenser son
savoir les foules elle est ancrée elle
est ancrée profondément dans les textes
de loi dans le statut des enseignants
chercheurs la loi ne reconnaît que deux
formats celui du coup magistral où les
étudiants sont principalement à 6 écoute
l'enseignant et l'enseignant
majoritairement tarn et celui qu'on
appelle les travaux dirigés ou il ya des
souvent les effectifs plus courts et
l'enseignement plus pratique est parmi
l'une format il y en a qui rémunéraient
plus le coup magistral et rémunérés 50 %
plus et pourtant la recherche on dit que
autres les deux en fait il faut mixer
les deux il faut que les cours soient
toujours en alternance
des missions d'information de réception
et de miser au travail des élèves de
mise en activité intellectuelle
alors finalement comment distinguer les
deux comment faire et dans la loi il
n'est pas écrit précisément ce qui
distingue d'un cours magistral d'un
travaux dirigés
alors cette question a été posée un jour
au tribunal administratif de lyon en
2007 en le disant qu'est ce qui
distingue est ce que c'est le nombre
d'étudiants par exemple un cours
magistral ya plus d'étudiants qui est
aidé et j'ai dit non la tribune sera
type de lyon a dit non ce n'est pas
millions d'étudiants qui distingue la
nature et l'enseignement le cours
magistral doit avoir d abord plutôt
théorique et surtout dans le coup
magistral
il ne doit avoir absolument aucune
interaction avec les étudiants autrement
dit on vient on parle et même pas une
question est ce format là et plus
rémunérées voilà donc un changement
profond à faire dans l'institution il ya
un changement à faire au niveau de
représentation
et donc ça des finances et la question
c'est ce qu'on doit vraiment le relever
est ce qu'on doit passer beaucoup
d'énergie alors je vous pose une
question je voudrais présenter une
analogie
imaginez vous êtes malade et vous allez
voir un médecin et on propose un premier
médicament pour calais il ya 65 % de
réussite
autrement dit vous avez une chose sur
trois ne pas être guéri puis vous
propose ensuite un autre médicament
celui-là il ya 90 % de réussite
autrement dit vous avez une chance sur
dix d'être soigné lequel vous choisissez
évidemment vous allez choisir celui qui
a neuf chances sur dix ne fonctionne et
est ensuite très rapidement d'ailleurs
le premier médicament il sera oublié on
précisera que le 2ème plus efficace et
vous en tant que patient bas vous exigez
auriez d'avoir accès au meilleur
traitement médical possible alors je
pose la question suivante est ce que les
étudiants aussi eux n'auraient pas le
droit d'exiger d'avoir les meilleures
méthodes pédagogiques disponibles
la transmission la transmission de nos
connaissances de culture de nos savoirs
est essentiel c'est à travers elle conte
finalement les passer d'un statut
d'homme vivant dans des cavernes à la
mode homme comme on vit aujourd'hui dans
le milieu dans lequel envie et l'école
et l'enseignement supérieur sont des
formidables invention elles permettent
finalement 2
on se mettre en quelques années
seulement l'ensemble des connaissances
accumulées par l'humanité et je pense
que c'est notre devoir à tous de faire
que nous donnons accès aux meilleures
méthodes pédagogiques disponibles pour
les enfants et les étudiants
je remercie pour votre attention